to Ryan Laney for his Innovative
adaptation and deployment of AI driven
facial veiling technology to protect the
identities while preserving the humanity
of the subjects in the 2020 documentary
welcome to chechnya the academy presents
an award of commendation
[Applause]
[Music]
nervous
um
I'm thrilled to be here and to be
recognized for this contribution and to
be among so many accomplished colleagues
the other work here tonight and from
last year is just amazing to be
part of this group so um
thank you and to the members the academy
who contribute your time every year to
consider the Excellence of so many
projects
I'm honored that our work even gained
your attention and I'm humbled that you
found it worthy of this award
which affirms our hard work to carefully
Advance the use of the ethical use of
visual effects in non-fiction
storytelling
I'm proud to have been part of a project
that through solving its problems we
found a new way to present witness
testimony
um thank you to David France for the
imperative to tell these young people's
stories without obscuring their Humanity
his art for journalism showed the
atrocities through a powerful situations
that would have been possible to convey
from the normal witness Shadows
I think Alice henty the producer and
everyone at Public Square films who
along with David saw promise and a crazy
idea and then ventured with me down a
unread path
thank you to Johnny Hahn the visual
effects producer who made the
introduction to Public Square films and
who oversaw the data acquisition that
part of that camera set up that was
there and to Abraham Luna the actor who
sat in for our initial data test data
capture test and became the veil for
maxim and of course the maxim with for
without his bravery and challenging the
state of chechnya these abuses may never
have come to to public light
um I think all the young people who
agreed to be veiled and all of the
volunteers who
uh served as their human Shields
I also want to acknowledge Academia and
specifically researcher yingilau and
team whose paper on attribute transfer
gave us the notion for using faces like
art for the purpose of style transfer
our use of these kinds of neural
networks enabled us to create authentic
truthful representations of uh which can
convey complex emotions and create a
more meaningful and impactful connection
between the subjects on the screen and
the audience
while employing these new ideas we did
so within a standard visual effects
pipeline
um it's a workflow that's crafted over
the years
and that I've witnessed it amazing with
amazing teams and amazing Studios
through my career
it is the producers and supervisors and
facility pipeline groups at these
Studios who along with the academy it's
been a great deal of time and
thoughtfulness and setting the standards
of excellence for the way we move data
and picture
um
uh Oregon uh Brennan who was uh the
producer on the film archive producer
who stepped in to visual effects to
bridge the gap between visual effects
and documentary filmmaking
um and last certainly not least to the
woman who um convinced me that anything
is possible and taught me the value of
perseverance not to give up on things my
mom who's here with us tonight
um
about 25 years ago she said when you
when you win an Academy Award I have my
dress picked up
so
um you look marvelous
um I'm proud to be part of a tradition
of innovation and supporting The Art of
Storytelling and through that Innovation
we have pushed boundaries and and have
changed what's possible on screen so
thank you
foreign
[Music]